good afternoon everybody thank you for
coming out my name is David McNeil I'm a
developer I work at Llano cloud been
there for about three years and
basically what we do is we build out
cloud application infrastructure using
closure and a fair bit of Amazon Web
Services so I really like my job it's
great people good business good
technology and in particular for the
last year and a half or so I spent a lot
of time with the Amazon Kinesis service
so that's what I'll be talking about
today and if I kind of go back to a year
and a half ago trying to get my head
around what it is I can imagine myself
going to this page and seeing okay we've
got clickstream data we've got a pipe
and do some processing that sort of
thing not a lot to really get traction
on understanding what it is here but
some point along line I didn't evitable
you hear that okay it's basically a
hosted Kafka so you go over to Kafka and
you check that out now you see some more
technical me technical meet in
particular you see this this concept of
a distributed commit log being mentioned
and this turns out to be something that
you can get traction on you can start to
research and figure out and understand
what that is so what I'm going to do
today is try to accomplish two goals
first I'm going to try to share a mental
model of how to think of a distributed
commit log how it works and how you'd
make effective use of it and then as I
go through this I'm going to try to
provide some patterns based on our
experience techniques of using it to
achieve transaction processing and
here's really a difference from what I
would see and much of the many of the
blog posts and discussion about it or
people are using it for like clickstream
analysis where you're seeing what's
trending and you just kind of sloshing
the data about and some can spill
whereas our application we needed to
account for each and every event so we
wanted to make sure that we were
systematically processing all the events
so this was an area that seemed a bit of
a blind spot at least in my ability to
Google for things so this is kind of my
retrospective of things that I think
would have been useful to me a year and
a half ago getting started with this
technology so a few disclaimers Canisius
and Kafka are very similar but I'll be
talking
really primarily from the perspective of
Kinesis that's what I know that's the
terminology I'll use I believe that many
of these ideas translate to Kafka but I
won't be doing that here and I'll be
presenting patterns I really hope
they're taken as patterns not best
practices so as a pattern there's a
context in which it applies there's
trade-offs you know it's not Universal
rules about what you should do so rather
I'm hoping to contribute some ideas to
talk about different approaches that not
promote a best practice per se so we'll
start off dig into this idea of a commit
log at its core it's so simple I mean
you say it describe it to somebody and
it's hard to even believe that you could
have a discussion about it right they're
like what is it you just write things to
the log so you go to the log and the
basic idea is it's a log of everything
that happened and when you want to write
something you go to the end of the log
and you immutably write some record and
just an append-only fashion and so the
log just grows and has records in it not
very exciting at all and in fact there's
not really much action for me here on
the right side the interesting part is
really on the read side but it starts
out really simple so on the read side
the basic operation you do is you come
through and you read you read items out
of this log and the two main kind of
constraints that govern how you read it
is first you read it in sequence so you
just start at a point and then go
forward and the other key characteristic
here is you're doing non-destructive
reads so you're not like consuming the
records in a sense that like they
disappear you're merely observing those
records in the log and so now you're
free to come back later and observe them
again another application could observe
them etc so with Kinesis the the data
doesn't stay there forever so you can
imagine take this analogy too far the
scroll is like curling up there you get
a window of things that you can read by
default the records will stay in the log
for 24 hours if you're willing to pay
more you can turn that up and have them
be kept for up to 7 days so the idea is
you Amy really write these records in
somebody else can come in maybe multiple
people who come in and read them but
they need to read them within 24 hours
or else they're going to be gone so in
that sense it ends up looking like a
buffer right that's a buffer between
these writers and these readers and you
need to clear that buffer
not in a sense of destructively but just
getting them before they disappear so as
you go in to read there's three
different ways you can open an iterator
so all of these will just start at a
point and go forward in time but there's
three different kind of places you could
start at you could say I want an
iterator starting at the oldest item in
the log and that will just go to the
oldest item in the log and you'll start
reading forward from there you can ask
for the newest items and that really
kind of skips everything that's there
today and just goes to the head or the
tail of log and then as new items get
written
you'll receive those and you'll iterate
across those and the final is probably
the most useful it's to go to a specific
sequence number so basically this is the
pattern you're reading along you get to
a certain place and then you die or you
want to restart or something and when
you come back in you want to pick up
where you left off so you'd open up an
iterator by sequence number to point to
a specific place in the log where you
left off so now a bit more about what
actually goes into these records that
are written into the log basically
there's two fields that you provide as a
user as a caller you say here's the key
for this this item and here's a data the
payload so when you hear key don't think
like it's a global unique key think it's
a key that associates many of the
records together so for instance you
could keep a track of all the
transactions on an account the key might
naturally be like the account ID and
then you'd have a record for every
transaction that ties those together so
in addition to those two fields there's
this third field that the system Kinesis
will add in automatically and that's a
sequence number and that identifies the
the order in which the items were
received and that's what you would
reference when you make your sequence
number iterator you'd go to a specific
location so these three items are really
what make up a record for for our
discussion here today so there's the key
and there's the data payload and this
number the sequence number so I'm going
to switch gears in notation I'm going to
switch to this colored ball notation so
here it's a more compact way to
represent these three pieces of
information the color indicates that key
that I mentioned the payload the data is
inside of the ball and I'll show that
when it's important and I'll just omit
it in many cases and then the order the
C
number is rendered here by a consistent
pattern I'll use in the slides here is
that time goes from top to bottom so the
most recent records on the bottom the
oldest records are on the top the
sequence tells you you know basically
what the sequence number was all right
so now we can get into looking at what
Kinesis actually does so at the bottom
here I have these producers they all
come with their bucketfuls of records
that need to be written they might have
multiple threads don't I'm
simultaneously writing to all different
keys and what Kinesis does is it slurps
those up into the cloud because that's
that's where you'd want them right is up
in the cloud so they get slurped up and
it's relatively chaotic going in but
what Kinesis is going to do is it's
going to resolve all the race conditions
between which one came in win and it's
going to produce like a canonical here
is the sequence in which these are
considered to have been received so you
get this disorder going in and this nice
ordered sequence coming out the top but
it's not limited to that what actually
okay so then workers they're going to
come along and move down in top-down
fashion they'll read the oldest record
first and they'll sequence through these
records and process them but this is
Regan and the whole kind of distributed
nature of this commit log so we're
adding the distributed now to commit log
and so the output it's not a single
output stream but it'll actually be
charted and its sharded by key range so
you notice like all the red balls are in
one shard all the green ones are in
another right so at a given point in
time all the records with a given key
will be in a single shard so really what
you get out of this the guarantee you
get is not not that all the records are
globally ordered that's not really the
interesting aspect of it really what you
end up with is all the records are
ordered by key and the expectation is
that you'll be processing these shards
in parallel so concurrently so it's not
so much important about the global
ordering as it is making sure that the
the events are ordered by key so this is
now all the terminology for the Kinesis
stack that I'll talk about today you
have the producers at the bottom they're
all sending these records into a stream
that's true
is sharded and you have workers not
consuming them but but processing them
at the top alright so we might start off
small but of course all things Amazon
the expectation is we'll be able to
scale this up right so at the bottom
it's pretty natural to think about
scales like things Amazon hosts you can
hit this with many producers all at once
hammer in your bucketfuls of data in
fact the limits you'll get by default
from Amazon are you can do up to 50,000
rights per second to a stream for this
aggregate 15 megabytes per second and
you can get this increased if you need
more you can ask Amazon they'll increase
it or you can make additional streams so
you can shard it yourself basically by
having additional streams on the read
side it's actually limited by shard
because that's the thing of interest
that's what you're actually reading you
can read up to 2 megabytes per second
and this turns out to be really
important limitation you can do five
reads per second and that's not for
individual messages but I'll talk about
this more as we go through this this
turns out to be a key a key restriction
here all right so this might all seem
like fun and games and it is fun tech
it's it's good good stuff to work with
but of course like all things Amazon its
metered right and it's metered in this
miniscule micro fashion that's hard to
reason about but if you do the math it
works out to be this so for every shard
you're gonna pay 11 bucks per month you
know just for the privilege of having
the shard if you write to it at the max
rate you could possibly write you're
going to pay an additional buck 50 and
if you turn on that feature to extend
the storage beyond 24 hours you'll pay
an additional 15 dollars per month and
these are all for like a u.s. East
region or something like that so it's
yeah it's relatively cheap of course it
depends on how many shards you need but
certainly to get started with it's not
very expensive so now we can revisit
that initial analogy and understand now
well it's not just the single monolithic
log that's being written to there's
actually many write heads if you will
that are all writing to different logs
and for Kinesis you don't need to know
that it started you simply write to the
stream but when you go to read you have
to understand that you're reading from a
shard and you have to read from
The Shard you're supposed to so a lot of
times initially it can be hard to
understand like this looks like
messaging how is this different from
more traditional messaging so if I paint
with a really broad brush and just talk
about messaging systems and kind of
gross over generalization you could talk
about okay you've got all these
producers at the bottom throwing these
balls in this pit you got workers kind
of pulling them out this looks very
similar to what I just showed but of
course there's a key distinction here
these workers aren't coordinated right
they're all they're not getting items in
order in general they're just kind of
reaching then pulling one out and
they're all different colors mixed
together and that's what Kinesis one of
the key characteristics of what Kinesis
gives you it allows you to process these
records at scale in a way that you're
coordinating which workers are getting
which subsets of your of your keys and
they're in order a consistent order that
doesn't change over time all right so
we've got the shards we can read from
them but we have this problem we need to
coordinate who's going to be reading
from which shard when you want to just
start up a bunch of servers and say hey
go read from the stream so Amazon
provides some client-side code Kinesis
it's called the Kinesis client library
so it's not part of their service per se
it's clothes that you'd run on your
application and it will take care of a
lot of the kind of low-level details of
figuring out who's going to be reading
which shard at which time so what it
does is it'll design
it'll assign a lease or a lock to every
shard and then when you start up your
workers so you start up three workers
and there's three shards it will use the
Kinesis client library to sort out kind
of a balanced load across those two or
each of them would process one of the
shards and the Kinesis client library
does this by using dynamo so it stores a
record of what the leases are and and
who has them and what the sequence
number is for each of them in dynamo s--
there's no additional infrastructure for
you to set up and those ooh keeper or
anything like that so that's nice the
number of shards and the number of
workers can vary independently so here
if you start one worker and you have
three shards he'll just go out the
worker will go out and grab all three
leases and work on all three shards if
you end up starting up five workers and
they have three then there will be two
idle waiting for work essentially
alright so like I said all the
complexity here is in the read side so
one of the complexities of the read side
is you're not reading records
individually but you're actually reading
them in batches so that looks something
like this you're you're going along
through this stream you're processing it
and every time you do a read so one of
those five reads per second what you get
back is a batch starting at wherever
your iterator is going forward you get a
batch of records in sequence and so the
idea is you'd read those and you've got
this checkpoint that the kinases client
libraries keeping track of that's
keeping track of what sequence number
you've processed so that as you go back
to read it can pick up with a an
iterator from there so you've got a
checkpoint say on the last record you
pick up a batch you work through it and
the idea is you then when you complete
that batch you update the checkpoint and
grab a new batch so you work through it
in this kind of mini batch fashion and
this again is a little twist on kind of
traditional messaging like it's easy to
think of messaging is like event-driven
you're getting one you know processing
individual items but here it's really
key to understand your processing
batches of items and you're advancing
your iterator kind of in batch steps so
another wrinkle on the read side is what
you get is at least once delivery which
is kind of a convoluted way of saying
hey you're going to get duplicates and
you need to deal with it so how can that
happen it can happen from a variety of
reasons one reason is shown here you go
in as kind of the top worker here you
ask for a badge you're given one and
sort of unbeknownst to you maybe you in
a past life or maybe somebody else had
already asked for this batch almost
processed at all but then died before
they could update the checkpoint so
you're basically getting those records
again from your perspective it looks
like they're being replayed to you a
similar phenomenon that I think of as
these zombie workers is there might be
other workers out there simultaneously
that think they have the lease but
they've actually lost the lease so maybe
because of a network partition or their
VM was quest or something they no longer
hold the lease
but they haven't realized that yet so
they're walking around you know they're
dead they just don't know it they're
processing records and so really what
this ends up leading to is even though
you have this lease or this lock and the
messages are coming to you you can't
think of it as oh I'm exclusively
processing these you really need to be
paranoid and think of it as well I'm
getting this message for the umpteenth
time and there's a bunch of other people
processing it simultaneously how do I
think about my processing in that
context because that's really what it
takes to build this as a distributed
fault-tolerant system is to basically
assume the worst at all times and be
paranoid so this leads to the first
pattern that I'll present here it's
obviously a pretty basic one but a an
effective way to deal with this replay
is if it's possible make your record
processing processing identity basic
ideas if you get the records repeatedly
and you apply the kind of side effects
from them repeatedly it'll have the same
result no matter how many times you do
it so this doesn't come for free
there's work required there's a lot of
times very careful design that's
required to make this possible but I
think it's a key technique to talk about
so related to this as we talk about this
checkpointing mechanism at least I had
this problem early on it was easy for me
to think of well the checkpoint that's
the definitive statement of where I am
in the sequence but as we went through
some of our applications we realized
it's actually more effective if I think
of that checkmark that checkpoint the
heavy black one at the top being that's
kind of like a lower bound on how far
I've gotten or an upper bound how it is
but really I could keep track if I'm
willing to I could keep application
state that says oh for red I actually
know that I processed these two records
and if I update some state kind of
simultaneous with processing these
records and I keep track of what
sequence number I've received then even
if it gets replayed I'll understand
oh no I've actually processed that I
know where I'm at so the the check mark
then that the Kinesis client library
uses is just a bound doesn't
specifically say what I've processed and
this turns out to be useful for us even
if the record processing is idempotent
because just because it's I dumped it in
doesn't mean you want to do it right it
still takes CPU it still takes time
don't necessarily want to be doing that
especially if you have like kind of a
really bad scenario where you end up
needing to or bouncing back and
processing a bunch of records and if
you're going through thousands of
records that you've already processed
that can be really expensive so this is
the next pattern basically where an
option you have to deal with replay is
to keep track by key of the last
sequence number processed and again this
doesn't come for free this requires
keeping some additional state so you
need to balance the trade-offs here and
see if it makes sense all right next
topic still in the reading side is
talking about parallelizing the the
processing so obviously the shards you
can do parallel processing on the shards
but inevitably you'll come to the point
where you say okay yeah I don't want to
make another shard but I'd like you know
my processing is a bottleneck here and
I'd like to be able to process this
batch this shard in parallel so a
technique we've been using for this is
will have the worker read in a batch and
so that's a sequence of records and then
it'll rip through it and partition it
break it up into sub sequences by key so
here you've got all the yellow and green
ones you break it up into here's the
yellow sequence and here's the green
sequence so you preserve the order by
key but you're breaking it up and once
you break it up then you can farm it out
to a pool of threads that you have to a
pool of worker threads that you have to
run it and so this is recognizing that
really the invariant that we're
leveraging from Kinesis is not the
global ordering of events but it's the
ordering of events by key so this
doesn't violate that we're keeping them
in order by key I think it's also
interesting to think of this now once
you get to this point you can look at
this grey worker down here getting all
these yellow messages and it's not hard
to now start to think of that as like a
distributed object system or from
closure like a distributed actor that's
or distribute agent that's like a thing
that lives out there that potentially
has state like there's all these
producers shoving in all these messages
and they're all going to like that guy
in order and so it really enables a
style of processing if you think of it
like that that's pretty powerful so we
write this up we talk about what it
means to to do subsequence processing
and like all of them there's trade-offs
this really kind of drives you to now
want to scale up your processing nodes
which is kind of not the it's kind of
against the grain a little bit with all
the cloud stuff you want to really scale
out typically so I think if this is
really just giving us another dimension
so of course we can scale out but now
you can also talk about how we how we
scale up the nodes all right so yeah so
things go wrong you know building these
fault-tolerant systems it's not that
faults aren't going to happen it's you
know tolerating them so yeah so some
domains you simply don't care if you get
a record fails right you're doing some
clickstream analysis not to disparage
clickstream analysis but there might be
a domain where you don't really care for
a few records every once in a while fail
you can just chuck them but I'm
concerned with this this application
domain where every record counts so for
example these are say these are
transactions on accounts and you want to
balance you know sum them up to know
what the balance is on each account well
if you just throw out records in the
middle it's you're not gonna get the
right answer right so every record
matters how do you deal with errors in
this context and in particular it's like
I struggled I bashed my head against
this for a long time because with a
regular messaging system you reach in
you pull out an item you know you do
some processing if it fails you can just
kind of throw it back in and somebody
else will pick it up later you know
something will happen fine but here
we've got like this fire hose this
assembly line of all these records
coming through like one of them fails
like we can't like pull the lever stop
the line and say you know everything
stop and you know we're gonna figure
this out like things have to keep going
through if this is one read one fails
you know all the greens and yellows and
oranges we how do we keep them going and
how do we think about this so this I
spent a fair bit of time on this and one
of the things we came up with is to do
some work create some heuristics to try
to categorize what kind of errors were
seeing so we try to look at say we look
at the exceptions and this is inherently
hard right because
once you get an exception you're kind of
by definition off the beaten path right
it's hard to understand exactly what's
going on but you can apply some
heuristics so we look at and say well is
this an intrinsic error this is
something to do with the message itself
like a Poisson event that's coming
through or is this really something to
do with my environment like did I get
this message and I'm going out to hit a
database or go across a network and
something misconfigured and so we put in
place some heuristics to categorize
classify exceptions into these
categories and like I said there's
definitely trade-offs here it's very
challenging to sort through exception
handling or exception generation is
often a very poorly Specht part of the
the libraries that we use and so it can
be very fragile to rely on you know what
kind of exception you're getting and how
they're nested you know there's all
kinds of wrinkles here so a related
technique here is if we get an error so
this red one is failing we don't just
have to give up at that point especially
if we have this idea of identity
processing so we just retry like up to
some number of times just try it again
and maybe eventually that you know is a
transient error and everything's fine we
can carry on so as long as we don't do
that so long that it really jeopardizes
the the timing of the whole batch this
is a tool that we can use again it has
trade-offs yep okay so we're
categorizing the errors we're saying we
think this is environmental we think
this one is intrinsic but then that's
not really sufficient so say we have
this case and we look in here and we see
well basically every message is getting
an environmental error so we can apply
some common-sense and say well yeah I
think that's probably an environmental
problem but then what if you have
something like this where most of all
the messages are fine except this one
but it looks like it's actually an
environmental problem and this can
happen there's weird things that happen
so this led us to the point where you
said well it's not enough simply to
categorize them we also have to count
them and we have to look at this batch
and say you know how many of them are
actually failing if it's just one is it
pervasive and again couple this with
that other thing where you have a kind
of these two heuristics you're applying
and I really left out a category here if
you think about this so I talked about
well it might be
the event and it might be the
environment and the one I left out is
once hard to see sometimes like well it
might be me
like I might be the problem and you know
that could be a startling question to
ask but yeah I didn't write it up but we
also have a mechanism where the worker
can decide you know I think I'm actually
the problem and it can surrender its
leases at that point say hey I'm gonna
let somebody else kind of step in and
see if they can do better with this
alright so I mentioned at the beginning
kind of made a point of this that
reading records is not destructive you
can read them multiple times and what
this enables you to do now is have
multiple applications that are all
reading from the same stream the same
shards so the way this works is you know
these are the workers I've been showing
there for a particular application they
have their locks but there could be like
just like this two ships in the night
there could be these other workers out
there and they have their own set of
locks they keep in track of their own
checkpoints and they're just you know
reading the streams in parallel with me
streams are not reads are
non-destructive so that that works fine
there's no direct ties between these so
all those there's no direct ties there
is an indirect tie
so I mentioned you're limited to five
reads per second per shard and this is
per shard so it's it doesn't care how
many applications you're running it says
hey you can't do more than five reads
per second so if you focus on this a
little bit and they don't really call it
out in the docs but if you really focus
on this like the docs talk a ton about
scaling out right you can do however
many you know gigabytes per say you know
just tons of scale out if you focus on
this one what this really says is it's
producing there's a imposing a pretty
hard limit on the latency that you can
achieve through this system if you can
only read five times per second I mean
it's only over 200 milliseconds you can
go do reads the expected latency of
messages going through here is going to
be 100 milliseconds and now if you have
two applications that are reading that
means if you're going to do it in a fair
way you have to now read it half that
rate and so now you're doubling your
expected latency so this especially if
you know depending on your kind of real
requirements this can be a real bitter
pill here so one of the techniques we've
adopted for this is we've introduced
this idea of a composite worker or a
composite application so here I'm
showing we'll have one worker that goes
out and reads the the batches from the
shards and if we have two applications
they'll both be like a part of that
worker and as the the batches are read
they're handed a copy of those go to
both of those kind of internal separate
applications so this allows us to do
kind of two totally different kinds of
processing on the data without
compromising on that read rate without
introducing additional latency through
this pipeline so like all these this
definitely comes with a cost
so there's trade-offs here it gets
complicated you're thinking through like
okay we're trying to do checkpointing
well what if one of these applications
is successful the other ones not well
what do you do we're checkpointing at
that point there's other complications
like you're effectively yoking these two
applications together in terms of the
rate at which they're going through the
data so you're effectively you know the
slowest one is going to govern the rate
at which you can do the processing here
so there's there's definitely trade-offs
ok so I've been talking about the shards
as if they were static but it's in my
opinion it's a mistake in terms of the
way Kinesis wants you to operate to
think of the shards of static so you
need to write your code you can't assume
there's a certain set of shard you can't
assume what key ranges are in them
rather you need to assume that it's
dynamic it's changing over time and you
just need to adapt to whatever the world
is so to start to illustrate this here's
an example you see two shards again like
always time is going down and so at some
point we decide well we really need more
scale-out and so we split both of those
shards and now we have four and then
later we say well that was really too
many we combined to a home now we end up
with three so this is the real picture
that you have to deal with as a reader
of a stream is you need to understand
that you need to dynamically figure out
how many shards there are at a given
point in time and pross
and in terms of the order of processing
you know the constraint we're going for
is that the records are processed in
order by key and so that you can kind of
extend that idea here to shards as well
that is you have to process the shards
in order so you can kind of see here you
start at the top right you can't process
a shard until you've processed all of
its parents so the two at the top there
they have no living parents so you can
start with those and then once you
complete those now you can go to the
four shards beneath and once you
complete the two in the middle then you
can go to the one at the bottom so you
have to do the shard processing in order
and then of course within those you
process the records in order and if you
do that if I didn't make any mistakes
here if you follow this through you will
have processed all of the records by key
in order so I care
the red ones they're all like at a given
point in time they're all in one shard
the yellow ones all in one shard the
same way so this leads to one of my
favorite ways of visualizing over all
the Kinesis is doing and that's like
this so at the bottom you've got this
Khattak mess of all this stuff being
jammed into this funnel and then Kinesis
is working to resolve all the races
figure out a canonical ordering for
those and it's producing this kind of
tapestry here right of all these these
shards and so then your job as a reader
is to come through and and process that
with the level of parallelism that's
available at each stage so the the
Kinesis client library helps with this
quite a bit so if you think about these
these leases or these locks on shards
you'll have a changing number of locks
over time okay and this finally leads
then to the final pattern that I'll talk
about here and I haven't really talked
into talk much about applications state
but here at this point we've got this
worker the darker worker at the top is
has done some processing on the shard
and let's imagine it has some
application state so like if it's
keeping track of those account balances
maybe it's got the running balance for
every account that's in its shard and
then it comes to the point and says oh
my shard is done so it there's no more
work to do there but there's more work
to do on the subsequent shards so now
you can imagine if you have that state
the shard level state if you will you
now need to kind of break that up and
you need to take like well half of the
half the state needs to go to this one
new gray worker and half needs to go to
another one and that can be a really
tricky problem so one of the approaches
that we came up with for dealing with
this is to track our shard state not by
chard because shards are dynamic and
they're changing over time but rather to
track our shard state by partition key
so by the keys and the data and if you
do that so you can imagine like say you
have like a dynamo table and you want to
have the balances so for the key to the
table would be the the key from your
your stream and then another column and
have the balance so if you key it in
that way like with the grain of the
stream then when the shard splits or
merges you don't have to do anything to
split your shard state right it's just
accessible by key and so if you know
this new shard workers has all the even
accounts the other one has all the odd
accounts they just go access theirs from
the state so if you record the shard
state by partition key then you can make
the shard splits and shards shard merges
trivial in terms of state management but
like everything there's trade-offs here
there's additional expense to storing
that state and yeah there's there's
definitely other things to consider so
that's it those are the kind of the
basic patterns techniques that we've
developed in building some transaction
processing applications I'd like to
think that these are the you know that
these things this is what would have
helped me when I was starting out like a
year and a half ago so if somebody finds
use of it everyone really glad about
that so thank you all thank you for your
time
these are a couple of references that I
found particularly useful to crystallize
my thinking they're not affiliated with
me in any way they're just useful
resources and that's all I had I think I
have a few minutes for questions so any
yes do the upper version you can run in
your laptop okay so the question is when
you're testing Kinesis it's hard to test
this thing in the cloud do they have
something to test locally I'm not aware
of anything that Amazon has what we've
done is we've developed our own just
really lightweight in-memory data stream
that has very similar semantics so we
tend to do you know we have our tight
feedback cycle with that and then we're
sure to run our tests regularly against
Amazon to make sure we don't diverge so
it's like many Amazon services the
feature footprint is really really small
it's easy to replicate it's the mountain
of like the non-functional stuff that
they do that that's really what they
offer so yeah pretty sure previous slide
and behind him
right so the question is I think the
question is if you actually have a
Poisson event what do you do I failed to
comment on that that was a line I left
out so the technique we actually use is
as a technique I prefer at this point is
when you have that Poisson event and
it's really failing you can't stop the
assembly line so the idea is well
identify like off to the side say this
key is in error I think of it like
closure agents right the agent can be an
error at some point if you know closure
so you say that's an error and then any
events that you get for that key you
kind of shunt off to another area maybe
that's what you were saying I yeah you
have this queue of those and now you
need your assembly line can proceed
you know things go on and somebody's
somewhere as to come back and like sort
through what is this process all those
queued events and then get back on to
the main assembly line at some point
yeah yep
yes on the producer side what's the
question
you're right so I think the question is
on the producer side when you send
something you might fail and you might
have to send it again so that's another
source of duplicates that I didn't
mention so yeah I mean there's different
techniques one way is if you have an
identifier in the payload that you're
sending then it can be distinguished
downstream like if you say this is
account this is a transaction five and
then you send it twice then the
downstream they can they can understand
that and figure that out
so that's of course that's a source of
duplication which is kind of subtly
different than the duplication I talked
about but I think there's other
techniques to deal with it yeah right
so the may not main things we would
reach for would be like dynamo DB or an
in-memory cache like elastic cache or
something yeah yeah so can the clients
when they're reading control the
backsides I don't know actually I'm not
sure I'd have to check the docs yeah
yeah
so question is what sterilization to use
I don't know that I have the best advice
on this I'm I like for development time
JSON for the readability but then when
it comes to hard core production like
there's different constraints on you so
I wouldn't necessarily do that yeah yeah
so the question is do you know how you
figure out how far behind your workers
are or your consumers are that is one of
the most important metrics to monitor in
this thing because that's the heartbeat
of your system and so Kinesis actually
produces a metric so you can go in the
cloud watch and you can see how many
milliseconds behind your your workers
are yeah free chart yeah yeah so I'm
kind of embarrassed to say this actually
so do a ton of cloud work and it's
almost entirely with Amazon and I feel
like I'm missing out like I should
broaden my perspective but I tell you
it's so good and it's it works so well
that I'm really kind of I've blinders
right now on Amazon but kind of in
general in terms of career development
and broadening my understanding I would
love to see other providers and how they
handle this and in particular I know
there's a lot of similarities here
between Kinesis and Kafka but I haven't
personally done enough Kafka to really
understand all those so at some point I
would love to dig into that more and
understand what it does I still time I
do
anything else yes
yeah so with composite workers I
actually tried to make that point but
obviously I didn't make it clear enough
but yes you that will reduce you down to
the rate of your slowest application and
that's a definite problem
okay so yeah so do you so yes I would
say this so when you're making those
composite workers you can't just do that
blindly I think this is your point you
need to take into account what they're
doing so that you don't have like
unequal yoking right their yoke together
they need to be going at the same rate
they can't be going to dramatically
different rates yeah anyone else
no all right thank you I'm happy to talk
about this stuff I love this stuff so if
you want to come up front or whatever we
can talk more thanks